eine schule garantie patricia für unsere
kinder das sollte doch eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein und trotzdem
wir haben alle bundesländer angefragt
alle kultusminister bayern
kultusminister nachgehakt kein einziges
land will eine solche schule garantie
für nach den sommerferien geben und ich
mir schon sicher ich sehe mich im herbst
schon wieder im homeschooling waren wenn
mein sohn ich jetzt zwei gesagt wird
eingeschult und ich glaube er wird
eingeschult und sofort sitzen wir wieder
zu hause
dabei werden das eigentlich so einfach
lehrer einfach zack zack zack durch
impfen
das käme eigentlich einer schule
garantie eine unterrichtsgarantie gleich
aber immerhin kommt jetzt ein bisschen
bewegung in das ganze ethik als mitglied
wolfram henn hat sich nämlich für eine
corinna impfpflicht für lehrer
ausgesprochen eben um genau das zu
verhindern
er sagt lehrer und erzieher haben
aufgrund ihrer berufswahl eine ganz
besondere verantwortung gegenüber den
menschen die ihnen anvertraut sind und
ihren familien
darüber wollen wir auch sprechen wird
bild chef julian reichelt bei dem kurz
das telefon klingelt aber sagt zur sei
dran ist für uns heimat sogar anrufe das
machen wir kurz das ist wichtig weil wir
sind gerade live in der sendung und
haben eben noch über die ich gesprochen
ich rufe dich nach der sendung zurück
das gleiche auto aus kabul wichtig
turner ob sie läuten damit geht es am
schluss ist froh dass er dass er
überhaupt eine andere wenn er anruft und
ich muss eigentlich immer blut und
wasser ich habe ja selber meinen
ähnlichen job gemacht das selber zu
machen ist mir nie so nahe gegangen wie
es war schon eine ihm gerade wieder in
kabul überhaupt serie heraus aus dieser
taliban region jetzt von den taliban zu
impfpflicht wir reden über eine
impfpflicht für lehrer der professorin
aus dem ethikrat fordert genau das weil
das einer schule garantie an der
unterrichtsgarantie für unser kinder
gleich käme wenn die lehrer durch die
entfernen also sinnvoll impfpflicht für
lehrer
ich würde mir vielmehr ein
pflichtbewusstsein flächendeckend bei
lehrern wünschen was einfach zur
aufrechterhaltung der schulpflicht
geführt hätte und wir wissen ja schon
von corona das gibt es nicht wir wissen
schon vor corinna es gibt viel zeiten es
gibt
krankheiten bei lehrern die übersteigen
alles was wir sonst sollen krankheiten
in diesem land kennen das
pflichtbewusstsein die schulpflicht der
kinder mit sinn und leben zu erfüllen
indem man dann als lehrer auch zur
schule gibt gibt es flächendeckend schon
vor corona nicht so wie es das
eigentlich geben sollte und nach corona
eben noch weniger das bewusstsein
ich kann mich impfen lassen ich bin
freiwillig lehrer geworden ist einer der
wichtigsten berufe die es in unserer
gesellschaft gibt ich habe für die
kinder da zu sein also das was der herr
aus dem ethikrat er ihm gefordert hat
das ist das ist eine schöne annahme aber
wir haben ja während krone gesehen
sie stimmt einfach nicht die
gesellschaftliche realität ist niemand
wird in unserem land schneller und
fluchtartige im stich gelassen als
unsere kinder und in aller erster linie
natürlich von den lehrern die natürlich
auch hätten sagen können wir tun alles
dafür dass wir soviel aufrechte
unterricht wie möglich aufrecht halten
dass wir diesen ganzen für eltern ja
wahnsinn des homeschooling so gut und
inhalt stark wie möglich gestalten all
das ich glaube das ist die erfahrung die
nahezu alle eltern im land am ist ja
nicht passiert deswegen ich glaube die
impfpflicht wird nicht kommen ich würde
mir wünschen es bräuchte sie nicht meine
prognose ist weil sie nicht kommen wird
und weil es sie eigentlich braucht
werden wir das wovon du träumst kind
wird eingeschult so nicht erleben wir
dass die letzten jahre gekannt haben
sondern wir werden weiter stückl
unterricht vielleicht als flickenteppich
über unser land verteilt sind
ich muss sagen ich bin ein großer
verfechter der impfpflicht auch wenn ich
mich damit liebe zu schauen und zu
schaue ich weiß sehr unbeliebt mache
aber impfpflicht bedeutet er nicht man
wird gefesselt zum arzt getragen es
bedeutet einfach dass man zum beispiel
seinem beruf als lehrer oder lehrerin
dann nicht mehr ausüben kann das haben
wir bei den masern haben wenn er im
pflicht und ich finde es auch richtig
dass sie als hier auch richtig dass
kinder in die kita gehen oder in die
schule gehen gegen masern geimpft sein
müsste staatsdiener hast du auch eine
bestimmte verantwortung eine besondere
verantwortung aber das ist ja die und
kehren davor das ist ja genau der punkt
der staat ist ja offenbar das sehen wir
seit anderthalb jahren wir müssen nicht
mehr darüber diskutieren ob der staat
bereit ist diese besondere verantwortung
wahrzunehmen
der staat hat seine antwort gegeben der
staat ist nicht bereit diese besondere
verantwortung wahrzunehmen
das bittere ist ja wir haben ja
erstens der beliebteste satz den unsere
zuschauer vermutlich auch lieben wir
können da nichts machen das ist
ländersache
wenn es um unsere kinder geht dann kann
immer niemand irgendetwas machen
wir haben deswegen ja extra die länder
angefragt was tut ihr denn um zu wissen
wie viele lehrer sind geimpft wie viele
lehrer werden zurückkommen und wird es
denn nach den sommerferien schule geben
und die antwort war nichts in
verschiedenen deutschen dialekten nichts
nützte nichts
es wird einfach nichts getan dafür der
staat wird seiner verantwortung
gegenüber kindern in keiner weise
gerecht erwartet zwar dass auch
vollkommen zu recht dass wir als eltern
die schulpflicht sozusagen wahrnehmen
aber wenn wir unsere kinder dann dahin
schicken dann ist er leider keiner und
nach den sommerferien werden dann noch
weniger sein weil natürlich viele lehrer
selbst wenn die lehrer die
durchschnittliche impfquote in
deutschland die im moment bei was 65 70
prozent sind dann sprechen über 30
prozent der lehrer die nicht geimpft
sind ich tippe meine prognose wird noch
niedriger liegen aber nur angenommen die
reichen 30 prozent der lehrer sind dann
in deutschland nicht geimpft glaubt denn
ernsthaft irgendjemand dass diese
ungeimpften lehrer die sagen wir wollen
uns nicht beteiligen noch zur schule
gehen wird nein natürlich nicht mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren